We're live in five,
four,
three...
Let's begin, shall we?
In life
Discoveries usually lead
to more questions.
The only constant variable
is the unexpected.
We can't control it,
It’s only when
you look backwards,
that you see how
it was all connected.
Let’s begin, shall we.
Mm, it's perfect.
I like to cook.
It's just chemistry.
You’re on the verge of a major
scientific breakthrough.
This institution has a reputation
based on the
world class scientists.
Not the theories of
a pretty lab tech.
We have rules.
You’re firing me.
♫ Just stop your crying,
it's a sign of the times. ♫
[tires screech]
I would like to
offer you a job
as the host of
our cooking show.
Are you concussed?
No. You are poised to
become a TV star.
♫ Welcome to the final show. ♫
We are live in five,
four,
three-
Welcome viewers.
This is Supper at Six.
♫
[laughs]
Do I need a catch phrase?
Don't over think it.
Never understood
what that meant.
[laughs]
I stand proudly with the overlooked
workhorse of the kitchen,
women and baked potatoes.
What the F-
♫ Just stop your crying
have the time of your life ♫
You’ve got something
almost no one has,
♫ Breaking through the atmosphere ♫
a platform.
What you say matters.
Politics don't
belong in the kitchen.
A man wants his wife to make him
a drink after a long day at work.
Why do you assume that his
day was longer than hers?
Why don't you
make the drink?
♫ Just stop your crying
it's a sign of the times ♫
You are what I treasure
most in this world.
Not because you are pretty,
not because you are smart,
but because you
love me and I love you.
♫ We got to, we got to, away ♫
- I can't do it.
- You think you can't do it
then you do it anyway.
♫
Your ability to
change everything,
starts here.
♫
Children set the table; your mother
needs a moment to herself.